you know what we know about the dow is
it's very industrials heavy and what's
infrastructure it's industrials right
whereas the SP a little bit more to tack
a little bit more to financials which
tend to be driven by different elements
of the economy and different
relationship with inflation so I don't
know I'd have to look at those dates
pretty closely but it's interesting
relationship you're not going to be
that's a great point I've also got I
know if you want to jump in the terminal
but I've got the sector breakdown here
this is a part of it as Jeff points out
you've got big industrials about a 20%
weighting tech has a smaller weighting
now it's 17% but if you look at the S&P
Tech's a lot closer to about 2021
so if you're of the belief that there's
gonna be a big rework in terms of the
trade you know agreements and whatnot
then potentially some of those sort of
multinational and big tech companies had
some problems then you've also got
financials about 17% so that's gonna be
helping as well as we've seen those
financials do pretty pretty pretty well
big ly as they would say Piggly Wiggly a
big week I believe it's big-league well
you know that's that's related to the
story we're just talking about but the
steeper yield curves and and this is
true globally right we just saw it in
Germany we've seen a number of places
that's helping financials not just in
the US but around the world true for
industrials as well industrials
everywhere even in Asia are picking up
on this Trump having global implications
for bonds in stocks no absolutely
although having said that when you look
at how some of the companies within the
US are performing you point this out in
your latest note on equities which was
fairly bullish overall is small cap
companies are doing better than large
cap companies and maybe Oliver you can
speak to this chart here with the result
2000 outperforming the S&P 500
this is fascinating because as Jeff and
I were just talking about going into
this event the election the markets had
a very sort of risk-off kind of
mentality about the trumple Trump's of
potential Trump victories any volatility
we saw markets doing poorly on days in
which is close to well recession right
but now not only is it not risk off it
is extremely risk on people are finding
it advantageous to get into what is
typically the most high beta part of the
market here which is small caps but then
it comes back to the sector breakdown as
well the same thing is happening here
where they're heavily weighted to
financials that as we've shown before
painstakingly so that they are the most
hide to Trump's chances and it's also
domestic facing so if you're doing the
whole you know America first attitude
and you know we're gonna put all our
money here and you gotta figure
finance legs deregulation absolutely and
they probably also apparently might like
higher rates the either the big loan
loan you know lending part of the
business something you alluded to was
steepening yield curve having
ramifications across all asset classes I
got a chart here we're talking about the
ever controversial Fed model which tries
to come up with some relationship
between bond valuations and stocks if
bond yields go up that's bad for certain
categories of stocks what do you think
of stock valuations here in light of a
rising rate environment is there a
connection well there's always a
connection between interest rates and
and stock prices I think stocks being
very much tied more to earnings
prospects I think in the next year after
two years of an earnings recession then
necessarily where interest rates are
headed valuations may be under a little
bit of pressure given the uncertainty of
what a trump presidency means in terms
of how well govern but well we do know
his earnings likely at a turning point
know the lifeblood of the stock market
yeah when you look at profit margins and
I know that this is overall not just for
the US companies but for global
companies you say that they're in the
middle but not the top of a long-term
range 20 years right this is so
important you know 10 years ago when we
look at the Lost Decade here for the
equity market and for earnings one of
the reasons is profit margins weren't
all-time highs they are now just below
the long-term average that means we
don't have that drag of slowly drawing
down our revenue per unit anymore
and have to grow sales volume to keep up
with it that's great news for profits
going forward